google announced today various
strategies to help consumers act in a
more sustainable and eco-friendly way
now this is all quite light touch stuff
but considering how big a role these
companies play in our daily lives what
are their responsibilities and can big
tech help us go green so mariam just to
illustrate some of what they're doing
google have said that they're giving a
green badge to lower emission flights
and eco-friendly hotels they've also got
features like maps defaulting to
eco-friendly routes is this a good idea
is it going to help us
be nudged towards making more
sustainable choices in our lives
giving people more information and more
data is always going to make it easier
for them to make informed choices i
think that transparency is absolutely
great and i think that people will be
able to make those choices in an
informed way now but whether that
putting this responsibility on the
individual entirely is a good idea i
think quite it's it's not i think we
need to also understand that this is a
whole society that needs to act together
so if this helps people do their part
that's great but we can't stop here
we can't so how much further should we
go do you think then i mean you you
think the business tech company should
do more
well i think the big tech companies do
have one really big responsibility which
is about addressing misinformation about
climate change that is something that
they have in their control and has a
massive um impact on the way that
individuals
understand the climate crisis and that's
we've seen the influence these companies
have had in things from elections to
vaccines and so they need you take that
responsibility when it comes to
informational climate change as well
well it's interesting actually i think
because
google did say today that in a bid to
combat misinformation uh users who head
to google search with questions about
climate change they'll be shown data
from sources like the united nations as
well as trusted news sources on that
that issue that's what they've said
jerome what's your take on this what
role can these big companies play in
helping us change our behavior
this is a very encouraging step to see
from google and
tech companies in general but i think
that also we have to ensure that we
aren't placing the blame just like
miriam said everyday people did not
cause the climate crisis it was the
companies in socioeconomic systems that
created the climate crisis in the first
place so they must be the first and
foremost to to basically break the
solutions and that looks like them
changing their logistics in the supply
chain not telling everyday people that
they should make small incremental
choices it's in both and i think that's
that's really good because also i think
google has made some steps but we need
to see much more when it comes to the
next decade of mobilizing on a massive
steel to avert the worst um impacts
so very briefly you think they do have a
responsibility they're not just
companies who are free to do what they
like
oh they have an absolute responsibility
to protect people because they create
services that pollute the environment so
if they're continuing to do that they
have to say we're going to switch to
make sure we aren't continuing to harm
people in communities it's 100 on them
to change and it's a small
impact people have sorry to cut you off
to roam but we are out of time jerome
foster marion pasha really good sibo
thanks very much indeed